i think this guy's like 21. i think they
said they sold half a million what does
he know about this then
[Laughter]
bro got his first first wood and just
decided to create a product
still he's still on his first one what
if like
well you're 21 i mean
things weren't great yeah why why why do
you need this um
but basically i think he said they sold
like half a million dollars worth of
chocolate off this off this ad um and
like within a couple weeks or something
like that so it really like jumps
[Music]
i've got one interesting topic today
what do you got let's start there
you want to start with my thing yeah
start start with yours
so you're a 33 34 year old guy so you
probably haven't been to the doctor in
like 15 years but
accurate
yeah
men don't go to the doctors my wife's
gone and i'm sitting here doing this
podcast i'm wearing flip-flops but one
foot has a sock on and underwear that's
inside out because i didn't want to do
laundry so like yeah i mean
i'm a grown child too but uh
so listen uh have you been to the doctor
like with your wife or kid and noticed
that there's like these tv screens in
there
i have like in the waiting room you mean
in the waiting room but also like in the
doctor's office like in the actual
medical like in the room
in the waiting room but i'm kaiser and
those guys are cheap as hell so they
don't put them in the actual doctor's
office yeah kaiser what is kaiser's its
own network in hospital so they they
wouldn't apply to this but basically if
you go to most like an independent or
like a normal non-kaiser doctor there's
tv screens in the waiting room there's
tv screens in the hallway and then often
times now they've got tv screens in the
doctor's office
and so have you heard of this company
called outcome health
i've heard of this once before
maybe from you no i think it's actually
from our buddy sieva and i'm just going
to tell you three words i remember
100 million dollars
basically like waiting room tvs
and uh there's an indian dude who's the
founder those are the three things i
kind of know about yeah well you're
missing the fourth word which is fraud
okay gotcha
this was four years ago so maybe
something has come out since then so
i'm gonna tell you about this business
and i actually think that it's kind of
like pretty morally corrupt but it's
interesting nonetheless um and the
business model is actually good and
interesting but the guy who ran this
particular business sucked so basically
it was called outcome health it was
started by this guy named rishi and he
was out of chicago and he's like this
wonderkin prodigy whatever raise money
at a 5 or 10 billion dollar valuation
promised that he had or said he had 160
million in revenue turns out that was
nonsense it wasn't true and so he got
sued and it didn't turn out well at all
but listen to what their business was
it's actually pretty
again unethical i think but fascinating
so basically
do you would you watch never watch like
cable tv yeah of course so it's like all
toyota commercials and like
pharmaceuticals right
back to the earlier point dodge ram
yeah it's like dodge rammed and like
cialis
and
and that's one of the reasons is like on
google and on facebook and stuff like
that you can't really advertise
pharmaceuticals or at least the rules
are a little bit different and so
pharmaceutical companies are advertising
like crazy on tv something like 80 or 8
billion last year spent it's like the
third largest category and uh but they
spend like
way more so of the 20 million spent on
pharmaceutical ads like 15 million of
that is spent billion
billion is spent in the doctor's office
and so they do that by like giving them
free samples by giving them like those
like mugs and pens and just like [__]
like that just like swag
and so this guy came up with this idea
where basically he puts a tv
in the doctor's office and the tv is
like touch screen and it's free for the
doctor and it does some things like they
could like put like uh like the person's
chart on the tv or it's like interactive
and like all right so your foot's broken
and if we zoom in here it's this bone
and
but when you're not using it for that
reason
it's an advertising thing
so it like shows ads and they're not
selling the ad to the consumer because
the consumer
is not the one whose choice it is what
drugs are gonna get prescribed it's the
doctor and so the pharmaceuticals go to
outcome health and they say here's the
50 000 doctors who we're trying to reach
show me which of those you have your tv
in in in their office
and help us reach them and we'll pay you
a lot of money for that right and
theoretically this guy was full of it in
like the fourth year business he was
like yeah we're making like 160 million
dollars in ads and pharmaceutical ads
and now outcome health was eventually
acquired by another company and they're
actually doing it legitly and they're
making over they're properly making over
a hundred million dollars and it's all
from pharmaceutical ads on these
freaking screens what's he lying about
he lied about which doctors yet or he
lied about the revenue like they just
didn't have so
jay and jay johnson and johnson their
executives and their their ad sales
people would go to these doctors and
they're like wait a minute
this [__] company told us that
there's tvs here i don't see a tv
anywhere
and like it happened like dozens of
times like dude you said that there was
tvs and our ad was being seen by this
many people it ain't happening and so
they basically just lied they just said
that their tvs were in all of these
rooms they just thought that no one was
going to check and so their tvs weren't
actually there and so they built and but
they were building johnson johnson on
showing their cialis ad or whatever to
you know but it wasn't actually
happening
so he lied
but also pretty dude crazy put the tv
there well a stupid reason to lie like
go go get the tv at the doctor's office
it's not that expensive or hard to do to
get a tv in a doctor's office i just
think it's crazy though that like this
business model is like crazy fascinating
though it is kind of a good business
model but i think it's
the whole pharmaceutical
industry advertising is kind of like
[__] you know what i mean it's it's
like someone someone's gonna do this for
like uh so we saw we talked to that
company that was doing this on top but
putting you know screens on top of uber
uber cars which i uh i was totally
against like i thought that business
wasn't gonna work was i right or wrong
did it work i think
it looked like we were wrong because
they raised a bunch of money but again
who knows maybe there's maybe it's a you
know we got a rishi rishi in chicago
situation again here so i i don't know
but but that company
had did pretty well neither of us
invested in it um
there's other versions of this so the
question is like what are these captive
audiences
where you can go stick you can go create
an ad network right so it's like
um there's like physical places so like
i don't know high schools colleges like
what
can you just go put this in every dorm
um like in the country and then be like
hey you wanna reach college kids there's
no more effective place than this
because like you know every three
minutes we give out like a free you know
code for like a snapple from the vending
machine and then the other you know two
minutes are are just straight ads and so
it's like you know can you find captive
audiences in other ways and create a
network of like some highly desired um
like person like if the the key would be
you know could you somehow
um could you somehow do this around like
i don't know stay-at-home moms probably
not because there's like
they're spread out like that that's the
thing with doctor's office is like
there's there's there's a
smaller number of them that you need to
like get the screens about high value
there's this company called cheddar do
you remember cheddar
cheddar was basically like
the hustle
if it focused on all the weird [__]
instead of just like
the substance and then somehow sold for
200 million dollars
that's my take on cheddar so you're
forgetting the worst component is that
it was entirely built at first on
facebook live so right when facebook
came out with facebook live this guy
named john steinberg who's a nice guy
and he's a he's a bulldog this guy is
like ari gold like if he sees what he
wants and he's like a just it's like a
missile he just
just captures on it he just goes
straight towards it so anyway this guy
launches company called cheddar and the
content was [__] and somehow they got
like they're on the news
the pitch right so here was his pitch
and how he raised a bunch of money from
investors he said
very similar to what you said hey
millennials gen z these guys are not
trying to watch
you know cnbc or msnbc or i don't know
whatever the finance channel is i don't
even know what that that's cnbc the the
pitch was cnbc only has like 20 000
concurrent viewer viewers at any given
point but it makes like a billion
dollars a year right and they're all on
medicare so it's like okay so how do you
get like gen z millennials they're not
going to watch that what are they going
to watch and he's like
social media
social media right and all the vcs have
nod their head he's like that's do you
have a teenager do they watch cnbc or do
they watch social media and everyone's
like social media he's like and guess
what they now have live video facebook
is live video twitter has live video
youtube best live video so we're gonna
create cnbc
on social media and they basically
created a 24 7
like tv tv show that was business news
that would just be streaming all day
onto facebook live onto twitter live
onto like youtube live onto all these
different platforms
that in itself is amazing building 24 7
is crazy it's crazy
so that is amazing that he could even
pull it off but there was one
factor that he kind of screwed up on
which is like
no one wanted to watch it yeah everyone
rolled right past it
yeah no one it's so his like he executed
a bad premise wonderfully yeah 10 out of
10 hustle
2 out of 10 idea because
guess what happens on social media you
don't stop and watch live video for 40
minutes like that's just not what
happens on most social media and so you
know just didn't really work and you're
right and 24 7 it was kind of boring
because
this is not 24 7 worth of like
interestingness when it comes to that
stuff and he raised money i think he
raised 40 million and somehow a cable
company bought it for 200 million
dollars and he told me i met with him
and he told me one time he was like yeah
so i'm gonna start this company and in
two years i'm probably gonna sell it for
two or three hundred million dollars he
just told me and he just called this
shot and he's a bulldog and he nailed it
he's an unstoppable force and he pulled
it off
but now what they do is if you go to a
gas station you don't even go to gas
stations anymore no dude dude i pump my
own gas yes i do uh if you'll see
cheddar all on their little screens
and so they're like owning like this
weird market of people who want to play
like jeopardy while they're pumping
their gas like you know it's like
snapple snapple facts while you're while
you're like doing your gas so they
they're they've got the gas market well
who was it that we did we meet somebody
i i mean it was just me i met somebody
recently who was like
yeah you know what a gas station those
screens like i own the ad inventory of
like these like in these like three
cities uh like i'm like the kind of main
guy so like you know how do you think i
should sell these ads uh
he's like i i that's what i own i own
this inventory i wasn't making money
i'm sure he was doing okay but he was
like you know what would you do and i
was like
i was like well the people who want this
ad is like the local businesses right
because they have like look you can
actually send them like local foot
traffic
better than like a facebook or a google
or these like scaled easy to use ad
platforms can dude selling local ads is
the worst though there's like these like
san francisco based i remember i had a
couple san francisco-based yelp friends
and they were like they were like like
like have you seen that scene in the get
rich or die trying with 50 cent where
he's selling drugs and like one
guy goes up to one of the drug dealers
and tries to buy like some crack but
with like quarters and nickels and the
drug dealer smacks it out of his hand
and 50 goes hey man come here i'll take
it it was like see how hard i hustled i
was willing to take the change and like
the yelp is like that version of ad
sales people like they would like find
like a pie shop and sell a 400 ad you
know what i mean and they're just
grinding to get that done
yeah there's just guys in the yelp sales
office dude i would watch a 24 7 feed of
yelp sales office because those guys are
the grimiest
grittiest salespeople on earth they will
shake your local pie shop down be like
hope you don't want this review that i
just posted on your page don't go
[__] write a horrible review on your
page and then call you tell you to go
look at it and then sell you a premium
plan that will get that ad removed it's
like the craziest thing in the world
yeah dude it's a racket and like put
grandma on the phone put her on the
phone
grandma
stop making pies
they're basically like the mob
like
do you want protection and then like
they do something bad if they don't
from us
they are like a mob yeah totally totally
it's it is crazy so those local ads suck
man i i've uh when i've got friends who
want to start like local ads or local
newsletters and i'm like yeah you're
going to get tons of eyeballs the
problem is monetizing that sucks man you
got to deal with like you know like
bob's steaks and chops down the street
and like
he's like well i'll give you like 30
pounds of filet mignon
i kept this great deal for milk road i
was like okay what's our fill rate i
think our ad fill rate was like 75 or
something last month
i was like it was 75
yeah i was like ben what that's pretty
good i was like what do we do with this
other 25 and he's like um he's like dude
uh you know he's like we actually got
hit up by a couple brands that you have
said you liked on the podcast he's like
they were just like yo we'll take any ad
that you don't have that day
but we'll take it at 40 of the list
price
um and i'm gonna give it to you in store
credit so it's like the worst deal it's
like you know i'm getting shook down by
yelp here but i was also like i kind of
love that product so yeah like let's do
it so i have like you know like right in
front of my front door right now i have
like
like you know pallets of fit aid because
i just like ran a fitting ad for them
and it's like oh here's you know two
thousand dollars of fit aid
you know in exchange for that ad thank
you so much
and so i'm like all right great my gym
has like you know
energy drinks for the year and it's done
that's actually pretty smart and it's
really smart on their part it's part of
their part and ben was like yo tell me
like the five or five or six products
you're like you love the most he's like
i'm doing mine too
and like we'll just we'll give
sweetheart deals to all these companies
like if we actually want their free
product like if we really want their
free product this is a great way to do
it and it's like it's a great deal for
them too they just get this like ad hoc
remnant inventory i told you this off
air but when the hustle started in order
to get advertisers did you notice that
when you started milk road when you
started having ads you would get more
people emailing you asking to
advertising exactly yes and so i noticed
that early on i was like if or i didn't
notice it i guess i was like if we put
ads in there we're gonna get more ads
and so i was like well like what's like
the most famous brands of people who
don't who who everyone knows of but
hopefully their employees don't read the
hustle and so in the early stages like
you know like it'd be like the hustle
brought to you by ford and i had never
talked to anyone in my life i just put
their logo in there and said i was
sponsored by them and i remember like
hopefully ford do you guys i'm sorry but
basically
i love ford i had an f-150 i love ford
but basically that's illegal i mean
that's illegal you can't do that and i
didn't know that it was illegal i was
like oh just put like you know microsoft
in here like put forward whatever who
cares like hey a free ad for them right
i'm giving them something
yeah and i would put that in there and
then immediately like there you know
someone would email me and then
eventually i noticed that if i put a
brand's ad in there their competitors
would call me to advertise right and
this one i won't even i'm not going to
say but i would put in certain tech
brands i'm like dude this particular
this company x has a really big ad
budget but they're not emailing me let's
go and advertise y which is their a
direct competitor and put them in there
and then immediately after and then
sometimes what i would do is i would
only put that particular ad in the email
that was going to that company
because with email newsletters you'd be
like oh wow there's eight people that
have an uber.com email let's send an
email with a message just to them
here's a lyft takeover email for them
so i'm like a mini rishi a little a
little mini outcome health here but uh
yeah by the way that's that's kind of
counter-intuitive like that oh if i put
ads that's actually the easiest way to
sell more ads and then
being sort of you know
you know fake it till you make it yeah i
think that's like the startup way um
there is a line i don't think i
personally don't think you crossed it i
did i don't think either with the
podcast by the way it was the same thing
somebody was like you know uh it's like
i had this conversation on the way
somebody was like oh dude love the
podcast and they're like uh how much you
making on that i was like
uh not really megan
you know
much here you know it's a i do this for
fun but then it's kind of like ate at me
and during my uber ride to the thing i
was like okay i'm gonna get a you know
i'm gonna get an ad it was like the
first or second podcast i made a third
podcast i was like i'm gonna get like a
sponsor i was like okay do i really want
to go do outreach to sponsors no way so
i was like um i just in the middle of
the podcast after i go i go and by the
way today's today's episode is brought
to you by
no one
no one answered today's episode i like
made it a joke and i was like but think
about it you could have me right here
explaining your product i could be like
wow it does this and it doesn't and i
just like did this like fake ad read
like for nothing and i just like
whatever i just like did that
dude the next day i got so many like as
soon as that episode released we got
like our first three sponsors just from
that like brought to you by nobody
ad and so i was like oh that was like
the hack for ad sales was uh you know
just because embarrass myself a little
bit on the pod well the reason it works
and this is something that i learned
along the way was marketers a good
marketer is a shark and what they do is
they spend most of their time seeking
out underpriced new platforms and new
places to advertise the way that
marketing typically works is you find
one thing that works you spend all the
money and you crush and destroy it and
you strangle it and then you go all
right that's exhausted move on next
and so you are constantly saying
the middle step then you go tell
everybody about how this ad channel is
crushing for you
you uh you get well-known you sell a
course on that meanwhile you've moved on
to the next channel yeah it's not
saturated and you go do that and then
you're silent until that one stops being
like fruitful and you do the same thing
you sell the course you talk about it
and then you move on again and you do
the same thing and so whenever you see
like a new podcast that you think has
potential or you see a newsletter or
like um uh
tick tock ads or a good example like
dude they're probably gonna crush once
they open it up um which they are and
that's how marketers work and
the smart marketers early on would
approach me and they go hey can we just
buy it out for the year and at the time
i was like yeah definitely i'm poor i
need everything and then i realized oh
no that's stupid because we're gonna
grow a lot and i know what they're doing
and they're smart
right have you seen um did i send you
this tick tock ad for uh tabs chocolate
i don't know you've been sending me all
these messages i didn't realize it until
two nights ago that i even had an inbox
on tiktok all right i'm gonna show you
what i think is the best ad um i've seen
in like
i mean i don't want to say my whole life
but i can't really think of a better ad
so i'm just gonna give this guy mad
props about this ad
this company riverside just raised like
40 we're so right now shounen are using
this podcast thing called riverside they
just raised like 40 million dollars so
it better work tell me this is not the
best ad you've ever seen and i'll i'll
break down why that's good so first
explain what it is for somebody who's
not watching the youtube channel they're
not so there's this attractive
19 year old
right or 21 year old woman and she says
y'all let me let me put you on and uh
this is a special chocolate that will
change your love life seriously it shows
her and her boyfriend each taking a tab
of the chocolate and then it shows her
again uh with her hair having sex hair
like it's implying that she just had sex
and uh and then it just says it works at
the end of it and uh okay so this ad has
650 000 likes went viral
um it got featured in vice and a bunch
of other places because the brilliance
of this so why is this ad brilliant so
first the hook the first hook is her
she's covered she's got her hand
covering her face partially which is
like with like the kind of like oh my
god and then it says y'all but it's real
this is a real
like this is like a real thing this was
a this was i think he created this ad
this wasn't no
what i mean is it doesn't look like a
highly produced thing it literally just
looks like a woman holding a selfie yeah
she's hold her phone okay this this
and then there's a there's like a
whatever a viral song right after that
and it looks like she's saying oh my god
let me tell you something and then this
it zooms in on her eyes and she's just
like moving her eyes in that way of like
that like sort of a mischievous thing
and then the next scene is it shows the
packaging
but there's also like a little like
there's like another thing on the table
so you kind of don't it doesn't again it
doesn't scream ad at you right like it's
not like this beautifully like a normal
marketer would say well get this like
you know candle that you have out of
here that's confusing and she's like no
like make it look like a desk and then
like put the put the packaging of the
product and it says this quote unquote
special chocolate will change your love
life dot dot dot seriously okay so now
i'm like intrigued it zooms in on it and
then it goes
it shows the guy and the girl each
breaking off a piece like half and half
of this thing so hey that looks kind of
fun to do
um
and then it doesn't tell you anything
about it except it goes to her with the
disheveled hair uh the jbf hair as they
used to say in college if you know what
that stands for and then uh it just says
it works with the shocked face and then
it's again her looking around like oh my
god dude what is okay so i actually
don't know what does jbf mean i didn't
go to like cool
just been just been after ah um
so
so so basically you
why is this amazing this is amazing
because to me the best ads have three
components
they have the hook
which is like just a thing to like draw
you in to even get you to pay attention
which is in her case the her with the
hand over face the second thing it has
is the promise
so it has the the promise that gets me
curious and in this case is this quote
unquote special chocolate will change
your love life dot dot seriously
and then it has the it skips to the end
right i have moved straight to the end
it has the implication of it working so
it doesn't tell you how it works
why it works though you know what it
does exactly it's just the the end state
takes you straight to the happy ending
of
this is life if you use our product
and um most people don't like most
people don't know how to do a hook
they get usually they get how to do a
promise and then
very rarely do people know how to use
the implication which is
th this is this is if this works here's
what happens to your life you kind of
just show the ending and people just
want to get into that
and so they kind of put put two and two
together about you know how how this
might work they want to click to learn
more so that's why to me this is an
amazing ad
and this is called tab chocolate if you
look at the rest of their tick tocks
they're all doing the same thing it's
all like um you and your husband when
you first get married and it's like them
like wanting to have sex and then it's
like 10 years after marriage and it's
like the wife trying to be sexy and the
husband ignores her and then they show
now here's you with tab and it shows
them wanting to have sex
so like an easy thing to advertise for
well kind of easy but uh
what's this company about are they
killing it yeah so they basically are a
d2c company i want to give the founder a
shout out i think his name is oliver i
want to say oliver let me see uh and
what's in this chocolate what what what
makes you horny i don't even know
dude i don't know probably nothing
doesn't matter uh yeah this guy oliver
i see this guy all of her on uh on
twitter he's young i think this guy's
like 21 i think they said they sold half
a million what does he know about this
then
bro got his first first wood and just
decided to create a product
still he's still on his first one what
if like
well you're 21 i mean
things were great yeah
why do you need this um
but basically i think he said they sold
like half a million dollars worth of
chocolate off this off this ad
um and like within a couple weeks or
something like that so it really like
jumps jumps
is it a bootstrap company i mean just
tab.com would cost half a million
dollars he has tab.com right so one of
the guys jake his thing says freshman at
university of michigan which is just
kind of insane and is that true uh let
me find this other guy oliver
there's no way this do you think it's
founded by it so this guy i'm gonna
study this guy's uh twitter which is
just hilarious
wasn't that long ago that this whole
operation was just the captain me and a
couple of parents
but hubspot helped us grow our business
across all seven seats hey celebratory
cannons
hubspot grow better
first of all so this guy's handle is
oliver
oliver underscore b1 or something like
that or maybe 200 scores but his name is
oliver b that says slash i sell sex
chocolate that's his name
on twitter then you know he's got his
photo which is like him with his bros
um
and yeah he's he's been tweeting out
like you know how um
you know how it's been doing so you know
they did 73 000 this week
um
he's like i have this army of user
generated content creators so like he's
like i basically have um
you know
i think he's got like an army of like 20
creators and he'll pay them between 500
and 3 000
and then they make 30 videos um they
make 30 videos a month or something he's
being a little uh loose with that word
army maybe a gaggle he's got a gaggle of
got a supper
party yeah he's got like a
he's got like a like a full he's got
like a full nhl team
that's the classroom
behind him i'll have a good touch
football
football game worth of uh creators i
want to know about army 20.
[Laughter]
but honestly this guy knows more about
marketing than like half of the uh you
know marketing gurus that you see on
social media just go look at this guy's
content
no they're they're like um i think
they're bootstrapped i don't know i
don't know much about them i'm kind of
making up half of the stuff as i'm going
along here but i know enough that's this
is that's an amazing ad
these guys are young these guys
understand marketing at a pretty deep
level especially on new channels like
tick tock and um
and that they've done you know like a
pretty decent amount of sales but i was
looking at like his like uh he had said
something he was like bragging about his
roads or something like that and uh
it actually wasn't super that part
wasn't super impressive so i i didn't
understand why he was bragging about
that do you so
this is kind of an interesting topic of
like basically
trying to reach like a young audience
you're trying to look cool then you go
and you hire like a young cool person
and you're like
make us look cool
yeah the best example was when we when i
hired steve bartlett and he's gone on to
do some amazing things we've talked
about him before
uh if you don't know he basically
ended up creating a marketing uh like a
whatever a marketing company marketing
agency that um
did like over 100 million dollars in
revenue it ended up merging with the
company went public he's like a dragon
on dragon's den he's got a real popular
podcast and a bunch of stuff he's like
to me he's the young black gary v that's
like the best description i can have of
him
and you think he's uh he's totally the
real deal
yeah he's the real deal um he's the real
deal in the sense that like uh you know
i don't know in the same way that we
were like dude gary v is awesome um
you know does he kind of put on for the
camera of course that's the game does
you know is vaynermedia the best
business i've ever seen no it's not the
best but it's a great you know it's
still a business that works and it's
like at scale
um so
uh you know real deal could mean a bunch
of things but i think steve's the real
deal in all of those terms meaning i've
seen his talent firsthand he's really
super talented uh so i recruited him
from the uk he flew over he lived with
us and and worked with us in san
francisco and then he then after that he
basically went spun out his like
marketing agency and like that's how he
kind of got his start
and uh and my whole thinking was like
this guy gets social this guy gets
social media he's a hustler
and like if we're gonna build these
social apps we need somebody who like
hey
they're
they're not like an engineer neckbeard
like who's like oh yeah people want to
share photo galleries because why would
i not want to share 128 photos instead
of one it's more it's like no dude
people don't want to share 128 they want
one disappearing photo actually because
i'm trying to send like you know
something you know inappropriate to my
friend i don't want this permanent
record right so like there's a big
difference of like what how an engineer
will build a social product versus how
somebody who's
you know social will build a social
product and and so i wanted to have
basically like somebody who was young
who was a user of every social platform
to be like hey dude just [__] test some
of these ideas and be like is this good
or is this not good and then secondly
uh when we have something good be able
to like blast it promote it on social in
a way that's not like uh cringe
and he did that like and so when we were
we were like all right
let me give you an example
at the time he had this like network of
pages he was like look i have all these
uh i either own or know the owners of
these twitter accounts that uh have you
know together like whatever 50 million
followers so when we're ready to launch
we'll post it there and i was like great
and so again the engineers were like all
right we're ready um and so i was you
know my brain went to like cool on all
these accounts post like
hey love this new app it lets you do x y
z and i love this new app bibo it lets
you do blank link and blank and then the
engineer is like oh and make sure we can
track the attribution so we're going to
use this like this url with this utm
parameter and they give me this url
that's like 9 000 characters long it
looks ugly as hell but it's like super
trackable they're like look at this in
the dashboard we know exactly who
clicked and which tweet and all this
stuff
and then steve was like um like all
right thanks for the suggestions
but um
not using that link in fact not using
any link because
uh nobody's posting a link and nobody
posts links on twitter and we're like
what like then how will they go download
the app he's like they'll go download it
if they hear about it a bunch and they
feel like they're missing out
and i was like yeah but that's like more
work he's like yeah but again they're
gonna feel like they're missing out not
that they're being sold to and then he's
like and we're also not gonna tweet hey
check out the new bibo app it has these
features he's like we're going to tweet
out memes like um
you know uh
my teacher when she sees me you know
like my teacher when she hears about
bibo for the 50th time today and it's
her throne it's a gif of a teacher
throwing a phone out this class window
and like shattering the window or like
you know um
my feel my mfw my you know my face
winner my feeling when
um i see
bebo trending on twitter you know after
10 years
and it's like um and i was like but that
sounds bad for us right they're annoyed
at us he's like yeah
get it it's like they're annoyed because
they've been hearing about it so much
and so somebody who's not hearing about
it it's gonna be like oh [__] i'm out of
the loop what is this and they're gonna
go google it find it
and i was like nah
this is stupid guess what he we did it
his way we launched we hit number one on
the app store charts hit uh i don't know
how many down i think we hit
250 000 downloads in like the first
month or something like that something
crazy and um
yeah it was like insane and we spent
zero dollars
so it was awesome
but
how did you get the the the
like the influencers
so steve owned a bunch of them so me
hiring steve was like me getting to use
steve's like assets and then he because
he had clout in like the social like
meme world of like the people who own
these pages uh he like pulled a favor it
was like yo post this on this day and
we're gonna get this to trend i need
this he was like a 21 year old trying to
prove himself so he's like yo i need you
to do me a favor here put this thing up
here so maybe we paid like a few
thousand dollars total but like you know
nothing to get like hundreds of
thousands of downloads and number one
rank in the overall app store charts um
and we did that let's see a pain in the
ass to employ though
no no he wasn't a pain in the ass but
i'll tell you first why i knew we needed
to hire steve so when we wanted to we
were building this app and we were like
all right this social app definitely
leans towards a younger audience we're
like all right we got to be like in like
in touch with you know high schoolers
basically
so i told jason and tyler i was like
guys we need to be like we need to be
able to pitch our app to high schoolers
and see what they think about it
and it's like all right well how the
hell are we gonna do that so first they
were like coming up with all these
schemes and i was like guys like um i
came visit him like an hour later and i
was like all right what's the what's the
point how many high schoolers you got
they're like none we're like coming up
with a powerpoint deck i'm like how are
you going to do this or something like
that they're like coming up with a plan
and i was like all right like let me put
it differently to you guys here's a
better question in the next hour how can
i show our app to like two high
schoolers go let's go make that happen
and they're like okay all right then
they got it they got what i was looking
for so they first were like all right my
nephew's on the line so we got the two
and i was like great how do we get 20
high schoolers now in the next hour and
they're like uh okay there's a bunch of
high schoolers over here at the mall
near our office like so they went over
there with a sign that said you know
uh test our app get a free burrito and
they got like immediately like 20 people
and they're like okay that was cool but
there was only 20 people there it's like
how are we going to do this regularly
and so we found a high school nearby and
so we went over there first they started
the same thing they had a sign outside
free burrito if you try our app and
people were signing up like crazy we
didn't have burritos by the way it was
just like a promise we were like i don't
know we'll figure out how to get you a
burrito later
and um
and then there so we got a bunch of
people to like try it out and then uh a
teacher came out and was like hey guys
what's going on here they're like oh
sorry sorry sorry we're not creeps we're
just like we're trying to get beta
testers for our app you know what that
word means uh and they were like oh cool
you're a startup and they're like come
on in and they invited us to come speak
they're like hey you know like you could
just like take over my class for the day
i'll just sit down and play sudoku and
you just teach my kids about startups
sounds like the most naive trusting
teacher like to a fault it was it
definitely was oh you're you're are you
a little kid lover
great come on in
you you must love kids so much you build
apps for them so you're a little kid
lover it was definitely worrisome like
why it was so easy but literally that's
what happened so for seven seven hours
straight that day like a class would
come in 50 kids we would teach them
about startups for 15 minutes and then
we'd pitch them our app for 15 minutes
and then we'd be like next and we and
but just by doing that you know to take
you know basically 30 kids per class
times seven we're getting 210 kids a day
in the same school to download our app
so that like all their friends were on
the app so it was a great it was like
this great way to like take over a high
school in a day and see if it goes viral
once we get that seed community
but in one of them we so the first day
we go and it's me and jason i'm like
dude it's cool i'm cool
and i was like i start talking i'm like
yeah that's tight and they start
giggling and i'm like oh [__] tight was
a cool word when i was in high school
that's i was like it's lit it's super
lit and they're like you know i was like
i was already outed it's like not cool
but
i was like and so i got like humbled big
time i'm like realizing and by the way
if you go talk to kid like high school
classic
they just don't give a [__] they don't
pay attention they'll just be like
straight talking to somebody else while
you're talking and you can't control
them at all and so i was like oh man
this teaching is so hard
and then i'm like and so i'm like okay
whatever let's skip to the end skip to
the part we test our app so it's like
all right you guys want to see our app
and they were like nobody says anything
i'm like okay um you know the first
person who downloads our app like you
know you get candy from this bowl and
they're like all right what's up and i
was like and i was like they're like
what's the name of it i was like oh it's
not in the app store yet it's on test
flight and
i can just feel the blood raining from
my body as i said that i was like what
the [__] were we thinking and then i was
like you were so just i was like i'm
gonna put the link up here on the
projector just like type that in and
it'll take you to the thing and this kid
in the back no joke he goes
links are gay
dude i was so
embarrassed and just i just got wrecked
and i started laughing so hard
i couldn't stopped laughing and i was
like
it was literally at the office from
there on out we were like hey
like hr we don't mean this in a bad way
but it's the funniest thing that just
happened the whole company is in on this
joke and so anytime somebody was like yo
send me the link like in slack and
somebody else would be like links are
dead
because it was the most
like you thought you got nagged i got
straight [__] slapped by this like 13
year old
[Laughter]
and it was unbelievable it was
unbelievable
by the way the other thing every high
school kid has just a cracked screen
none of them have a phone that is like
the screen intact they all got cracked
screens
you know what uh you know what i think
about everyone's so remember this
company called uh chubbies
yeah so basically they uh made shorts
for they made like short shorts and they
were great guys but like their customers
and we're just like bros like hard like
chad bro chill like the hardest the
hardest like bros you can think of and
uh which is like that's fine but i don't
want to be like 40 years old and having
to like make ads like
uh about summer and spring break like
you know like
you know what i mean like i don't know
i don't relate to that at all at least i
don't if i'm like 40. and it's kind of
like the uh bar stool guys it's like
man you're losing your hair you still
you want to be doing like these beer
bongs like and i think about like to
build a social app
or even like other
products like chubbies in that space and
to be a grown adult doing it it's kind
of uh
if that doesn't work it's super
embarrassing
i think you're going with some highly
intellectual
conclusion here
yeah you basically were like
like
like yeah you're kind of a loser
it's just embarrassing man like it's
like
it's cool because tick tock worked but
imagine a bunch of like like a 45 i
think the guy who started tick tock or
whatever what's it called bit uh
the owner of tik-tok i forget what it's
called bitnami or what's this [__] bite
dance like this like 43 year old chinese
guy trying to make products for like but
it worked dude
american girls like young 14 year old
american girls it's like yeah it's cool
because it worked but man this was like
this could go either way like this could
have gone either way and and like that's
kind of that's kind of scary to me not
scary but that's like another one we
built so after that app so we go through
that process that i get humiliated i'm
like oh my god
i go back to the team i'm like we are so
far disconnected from like our customer
like we thought we could go in there
teach them about startups as if they
give a [__] and then tell them to
download our test flight app from a link
and like you know
we all heard how that went down okay so
so so you know i got basically like i
was like a character in south park that
day so i got honed and then i was like
all right well let's so we pivot and we
try this other app that was like
the idea was like it ended up being what
house party was so us a house party at
the same time it was like
an app where it's like i don't want to
call somebody but like i'm you know like
i'm down to hang out if somebody else
happened to be like free at the same
time
and so it was this app where you could
just kind of say like you know
you could just say if you're available
and if other people aren't you can just
get into kind of a more spontaneous
conversation versus the phone call where
it's like dude what do you need from me
um but i was like well so they made the
app they made the prototype real quick
engineers are great again and then the
front screen they're like hey we need
some text for this like because right
now it just says like you know
push to begin or like you know you know
like initiate and i was like oh no
that's like we don't want to write like
initiate that's not going to work again
teenagers they don't like links uh what
do they like to do netflix and chill and
so i was like oh just make it like a
swipe like tinder i was like so so we
just said
swipe to chill
and like literally like the first
version said swipe to chill and the
we had one guy johnny dallas working for
us and he was a teenager so he was like
a 16 year old programmer
and he saw swiped chill and you could
just see him being like do i have to
share this with my friends like
with other people before i said to my
friends because it says swipe to chill
on the front and like that's not a thing
people say or do
[Laughter]
so it was all bad dude that sucks okay
so then let me tell you steve bartlett's
story all right so so i'm like we need
we need some young blood in this and
this office steve bartlett cold emails
me a great cold email i'm like this
guy's awesome fly him and his buddy out
and we're like you guys work for us now
you are kind of like our youth
department and um
how did they stay in america
uh there was no like visa now there's
not a tourist thing they came they could
stay for three months at a time and they
would go back and they would come again
and did they live at the office
they would live they got we got the
hotel but it was like they're staying
for a while so we were like all right
just stay at the office because there's
an apartment built in
and like you know just i don't know make
it work dude but did you ever think like
what did steve tell his parents like can
you imagine 20 year old or 19 year old
you like uh
explaining what's gonna happen yeah i
would have been like this is awesome and
i knew steve was wired like that so he
was also like this is awesome he didn't
he didn't bother telling his parents he
was like living his life so he he
thought this was great
so steve's there and our if you remember
our office stanford is kind of a baller
pad so steve basically went from like
living in like a dump like a tiny you
know like he was a college dropout in
the uk making no money to
he comes to the us and now he's living
in this like baller pad that has like a
bar built into it a private chef all
these like perks it just looks like it's
designed like i know straight out of
something like british magazine
and um
and steve would take advantage of that
so he was living there
and um so he would like you know people
would leave the office 6 7 p.m and then
what he would do is he would like go and
um you know he didn't invite friends
over he was on tinder tinder was active
and so we would come into the office in
the morning and like i remember one day
i came in and like some girl was like
leaving doing the walk of shame holding
her heels in her hand uh like walking
out and like you know we we had women
working in the office who were like
who's this girl like what and why is she
like hungover leaving the like the
bedroom in the office like what's going
on here and then steve would come down
he'd be like and he was like you know
proud of himself in a way he's like
dude i'm winning at life and so so that
was a little bit of a problem and then
i remember they were like
what did you say to him like hey you
know you can't even yes you are living
here but you can't live here yeah i
think i told him once but i remember
just like even in the conversation it
was like uh man he feels like he's in
the principal's office and i feel like
the principal
and like i could tell this is lame
because he wasn't doing anything out of
any malice right like it would just be
like they would just you know they'd be
hanging out drinking you know at the bar
we have in our office but they would
kind of like
leave the bars kind of sticky and with
beers they didn't know to like
you know just like some professionalism
stuff like that's a tuesday night i
should just like let me just at least
make this look like we weren't here
drinking and hanging out all night and
playing the music and the neighbors get
a noise complaint stuff like stuff like
that right nothing nothing harmful
nothing like uh bad just like
slightly annoying to people who felt
like they were parenting them in the
morning when they came in
um and like i remember one time the
funniest one and the one where i was
like uh this is just not working out
um
dude they had like or
they like uh i was talking to our office
manager and i was like i promise i
talked to steve they're they're not
gonna like play the music too loud and
like they'll clean up the beers or
whatever and like that happened one day
and then the next day no beers no loud
music it was all good and then she
opened up like the supply closet to like
get like some new pencils and like
sticky notes for the meeting we had like
the board meeting we had and like just a
giant pizza box spell out
why would you put a pizza in this closet
like just throw the pizza in the trash
and she was like these kids like i've i
can't do this shot i can't do this at
all did you fire him no no i didn't fire
him but i was like i kind of knew in my
head i was like you know what
birds gotta fly i was like these guys
they're talented they need to do their
own thing
them conforming into like our office
like set up and like
it's just not like a fit you know like
they don't need to run these meetings
like these daily stand-up meetings with
the engineers it's like that's not their
skill set that's not what they need to
do
like they're good at like taking
something that's dope and making it like
pop in the market like and they just
need to do that and then basically
that's what their marketing agent did
they would just find cool brands to work
with and they would figure out how to
tell that story and make it big and
trend in social media and it turns out
they were great at that and they made
went made like you know hundreds of
millions of dollars doing that and so
that was like a successful outcome but i
i kind of knew in my head i was like all
right there's these advantages when you
bring in these sort of like
these non-domesticated cats uh and
they're gonna like they're gonna be real
with you about what about the market
they're gonna like have fresh ideas
they're gonna be good at like
playing the social media game
but like you know they're not gonna be
the best at like you know
running this like you know agile
software like you know uh meeting this
is not what they you know they don't
need to be product managers they need to
be like out
about i remember i wrote a profile about
him when he was still pretty young and
it was working and it was like buzzfeed
or something i think it was buzzfeed and
he must have been only 23 or 24 and they
were like basically the office has like
a slide in there and like it was like
everything yeah
like a mcdonald's playpen it's my face
and he was like they've got like 40
employees here and i asked him how much
each person is getting paid and it was
like 25 000 a year it was like nothing
and but they like love it because it's
the first time a 21 year old is able to
like be the head of hr and like just
figure out stuff as she went and i was
like oh my god i don't know about those
numbers but i do remember at one point
it was like
they had 23 employees and
i think 22 of them were under the age of
22. like it was like all 21 year olds
and they were like and that was the
device article or the whatever vox
article or whatever it was it's just
like meet the 21 year olds who are
running the internet right now and it
was true like they were really they
owned all of the popular instagram and
twitter accounts in in europe and so
they just had like crazy ability to
influence the market
and
they had the right people to do it right
like that's who knew how to build that
was the business the business was brands
would pay to advertise on those twitter
and instagram handles
uh initially that's how we used it but
the and that was a part of it we were
like we created this like idea of like
this the thunderclap which was like
getting all those pages on the same day
to be talking about your brain came up
with that name
i remember saying it but i think other
people use that term so i don't think in
my head i invented it but i'm sure i
learned it i heard it somewhere i'm sure
um
but the thing what they were doing was
then they were they would just like a
brand would be like hey how do we what's
our social strategy so then it
they quickly got away from just like hey
pay to post on our pages because that's
kind of like transactional to to like
hey netflix do you want to know how to
do your social like why don't we just be
your agency of record for social media
for your social media marketing and like
that became with a fat retainer and like
ongoing campaigns and then like and then
they would like do like proper videos
and like kind of viral videos stunts
things like that whole strategies for
these brands so that's what it became
and then they launched their own brands
too we've been getting uh the past few
episodes we've been getting more into
just
trying to just telling funny stories i'm
very eager to see
uh if this is the route that we should
go it's way more fun that's for sure
yeah it's fun but after every episode i
have to like do like a cancellation
check-in and be like
was i um
sexist racist homophobic uh you know is
there anything that i said that could
have been construed as hateful in any
way to any group of people that is going
to be like offensive like i tweeted out
this thing the other day that's like and
by the way they're never hateful they're
always like a compliment
uh but like i tweeted out this thing
which was like you know my investment
criteria you know big market good
traction founder is mormon russian
jewish or whatever i like said something
but it was like positive it was like
because i think those founders like on
balance are awesome like i've had and it
was a joke and it was a joke right and
people were like what does race have
anything to do with who you'll fund this
is what's wrong with and i was like well
first of all it's a joke to be clear
like did you think this was serious and
secondly like it wasn't a joke saying i
don't fund these fun you know these
random niche minority groups it's like
no i think mormons are awesome at sales
and like you know just as a as a general
like positive prejudice you know i am
i'm inclined to believe that these
people are really smart or really
talented or really gritty or really
whatever
um
and you know but of course like there's
no winning right like the audience that
like gets that and thinks it's awesome
it's like so small compared to the like
the other audience that's like i will
make it my life's mission to like get
you canceled now for for this for this
uh this joke you said the um the nelk
boys which is like those youtube guys
now they got this they've got a new
podcast it's only good because
there's
they're not like good asking questions
but they're good because they're so
famous that they get like the best
guests so the elk boys had donald trump
on you know like one of the most famous
people in the world they had um you know
all types of like they had uh habib on
they had dana white on they have like
all these like hugely famous people
and they were talking to dave portnoy
and they were like uh yeah like we're
uncancelable because like everyone's
expectations of us are so low right and
like we're just degenerate so like they
don't everyone's like yeah of course
they did that thing like there's no
surprise there these guys are idiots and
uh
i'm not sure if we're there yet i don't
know for it
maybe
yeah do you want to be right like i call
it the cancellation vaccinations like do
you want to be vaccinated against
cancellation here's what it entails
you need to consistently be provocative
never apologize like cater to your base
and ignore the rest and like that's the
that's the cancellation of vaccinations
what joe rogan does what donald trump
does it's what the milk boys do it's
what any group of people dave chappelle
any group of people who like they're
like look i'm gonna say what's on my
mind
there's gonna be some people who are
offended by this that's not my audience
there's some people who understand the
point of view where i'm coming from
they're gonna understand what's a joke
they're gonna understand when i'm saying
something positive about somebody that
doesn't mean it's negative about
somebody else um and they're just like
and they're like i'm consistent i'm
willing to do this i'm willing to take
heat i'm not gonna apologize et cetera
et cetera and um
and so you know that's like the the
cancellation vaccination now i think you
do that i think you also need to be
financially independent or directly fan
supported and like you know for example
this is a hubspot podcast network
podcast you work at hubspot i don't
think they're gonna love some of the
jokes that you tell like even if that
person individually thinks it's funny
they'd rather us just take no risk right
why like
for them the risk reward you know
calculator is like oh just take no risks
and it's fine just like do your other
stuff it's great whereas for us it's
like dude no like i'm here to have a
conversation with sam
i want this to be like a conversation we
would actually have i think that's how
you get super fans because they feel
like you're being authentic you're not
you're not like separating the real you
from like this like record public
podcast version of you
and i know my intentions are pure i know
i'm not actually a bad guy i'm not
sexist racist or homophobic or any of
those things
and if i say that i think mormons are
awesome founders i think that that is
should be a
i think that should be a totally fine
thing to say right i you know i don't
think that's a controversial thing in my
books and so i'm like you know i'm part
of the common sense party and i want
other people who are you know like
confuse their common sense or are not
like easily offended around me
but that's a that's a risky path to take
that's a good speech i'm on board
good very good speech
all right i guess that's the episode
[Music]
you